hi kids I'm Johanna Stern a personal
tech columnist at The Wall Street
Journal and today we're going to be
reading my new book the book is called
mommy where's my photo going daddy
version sold separately once upon a time
in the land of the internet there was a
woman who loved to share photos of
everything her vacations her dinner her
dog her dogs dinner then she and her
partner had a baby and she started to
share photos of her son in the same way
until she realized sharing photos of her
son was not like sharing other stuff
unlike animals humans deserve privacy
and pants said bunny the man realized
that when you don't think before posting
about your child there are three
unintended consequences number one your
child will grow up to see this and may
not like it dude you're gonna like this
so much better than sitting in your
diaper said bunny share hey some privacy
kids get older and don't necessarily
want every photo ever taken of them out
there mom learned if your child is old
enough ask him or her how they feel
about the photo being shared if not
consider the embarrassment or anxiety
the photo could cause in the future
number two every photo is a piece of
info world cup here we come beautiful
day at Swan Park share hey that's her
location happy birthday to you insert
full name here can't believe you were
born just two years ago and share hey
that's his full name and birthday
shut it bunny our little guy had kidney
surgery today thanks for your prayers
share health info so mom began to think
about all the data shared on her feed
through the eyes of someone else a child
predator a hacker or a tech company
looking to gather more information about
her and her son if your account is
public make it private then comb through
your followers and unfriend or block
anyone you don't feel comfortable with
if you have a public account for work or
community interactions don't divulge any
private information experts who focus on
protecting children from predators say
don't post any photos of your kids at
bath time or nude don't use common
hashtags like hashtag naked child and
hashtag bath time fun what appears
innocent to you may not be to others
number three with artificial
intelligence and facial recognition
there's no telling what these photos
could be used for and share and share
share share share share share share
share mom thought about how a few years
from now all these photos of his face
could be used for things we aren't even
considering now for instance they could
be put through an app to make him say
something he didn't say or do something
he didn't do duh
they're called deep fakes mom privacy
experts worry about how they'll be used
especially by cyber bullies don't worry
dude we'll get through this as facial
recognition gets more advanced companies
could learn more about you using AI
Facebook has a facial recognition photo
tagging feature that you can turn off so
mom thought about this and that and this
and decided to stop sharing her son's
face on social media until he was older
if she posts she posted the back or side
of his head
some parents cover their kids face with
an emoji not that it's ever the bunny
emoji going cold turkey may be hard but
instead of using Facebook or Instagram
to broadcast to family and friends
mom now uses messaging apps or private
photo sharing services like Apple or
Google Photos whatever you do please
think before you share especially the
highly identifiable impersonal moments
or else we'll see how you like it hey
some privacy please
the end where's everyone anyone